cesa exercises Ki ASI leg
reversal
okay so this Kashi um is a really great
exercise to practice when you're going
to do a lot of kimy from cza um a lot of
times you're going to get knocked back
and need to bring your feet through um
otherwise you'll get trapped back here
so the ability to bring your feet
through as you're falling back will will
save you a lot of pain in your knees
this exercise can also be really
challenging for people at first so one
way I might recommend starting if you're
having a lot of problems with the
flexibility your ankles would be to
bring your weight forward and try pull
your feet through one or time so I'm
going to pull my feet through here so
here I pull my feet through and sit
myself back that'll relieve some of the
pressure but ideally you want to be
getting to a position where you can just
sit back and bring your legs through and
out if you're having problems when
you're falling back like this you can
also bring yourself back push yourself
up and over your ankles and bring them
out just going through this motion even
if you have to handicap yourself at
first will get you more and more used to
the flexibility you're going to need to
bring your legs through but ideally you
want to from right here from this
position be able to sink your legs
through back and bring them back in ki
ASI